c'est non non monsieur le procureur
général de la république des matches
moins 16 tu sais quoi occuper
[Musique]
eh bien monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les jurés toulouse one est
houleuse ouanès public chéri ce 5
février 1952 un froid intense figeait la
france entière sous un épais manteau de
givre mais comme le dit si bien
marguerite duras mieux vaut un bon petit
froid sec qu'une mauvaise petite pluie
fine
ce jour là la scène est prise dans les
glaces
la loire charité isbergues et je me
demande si moi même je ne suis pas un
peu givré
à cette époque la france se relève à
peine de sir win de sir robin provoquée
en grande partie par les bombardements
anglo-américains de 1945 financé par les
capitaux étrangers jeu vidéo plutôt
pratique
ce n'est pas vraiment le sujet du
réquisitoire contre daniel balavoine
mais pendant que j'y suis je pense qu'il
est bon de rappeler de temps en temps
aux français que quand même 70 % des
marines américains qui a participé au
débarquement en normandie le 6 juin 44
était franc maçon c'est pas tout ils ont
rien nettoyer on plaisent pas
c'est vrai merci m et les 30 autres %
étaient des [ __ ] de tendance
communiste faut le dire de temps
maréchal 25 merci marc f par sam février
1952 il y a un an jour pour jour à six
mois après le maréchal pétain
s'éteignait semble aller mieux
quand je dis qu'il s'éteignait sans
bruit craquer un peu quand même
les obsèques du vainqueur de verdun
furent très émouvante mesdames et
messieurs à l'entrée de l'église
juliette bois rivaux et eliane victor
vendait le numéro un de l homme sa vie
ça le premier hebdomadaire féminin haut
en couleur je revois encore la
couverture y avait une photo de madame
delattre-de-tassigny en noir et le texte
c'était cette semaine comment être la
plus belle pour aller à l'enterrement
magnifique numéro deux dans la nef
albert ii lâche le génial inventeur de
la minute de silence fermer sa gueule
c'était une très très belle cérémonie
mais revenons à ce 5 février 1952 rue de
grenelle où se trouvait alors le siège
de la radio française parisienne le
speaker de paris inter venait de
s'interrompre dans la lecture des cours
de la bourse
comme le disait si bien le regretté
roland barthes
mieux vaut être cours de la bourse que
l'on de coeur
alors mieux vaut mieux vaut faire la
queue à la bourse
là ça va ça sperian ces pointures grâce
à faire et je vous prie de m'excuser
donc donc le speaker de paris inter
s'interrompit soudain dans la lecture
des cours de la bourse
edit j'ai la dépêche afp en main
mesdames et messieurs on m'apporte à
l'instant une dépêche de dernière minute
qui nous annonce mon dieu oui c'est cela
il n'y a pas de doute on annonce à
alençon la naissance d'un garçon
domicile de monsieur et madame balavoine
les célèbres fonctionnaire moyen du sud
ouest et de sources généralement bien
informées
l'enfant ne serait autre que daniel
balavoine le président edgar faure a
d'ailleurs envoyé un télégramme de
félicitations à la famille avant de
s'envoler pour saïlgoh où les forces
vives mines sont pour ainsi dire
complètement écrasée réfléchissons un
peu février 52 décembre 80 près de 55
ans au passé 41 ans au passé pouf pouf
février 52 des 180 le temps a passé
après une courte carrière de chanteur au
cours de laquelle sa voix de tête de
cheval sa voix de tête à cheval
entre-t-il rossi et luis mariano lui
vaut la faveur d'un pub quand je dis à
cheval entre tino rossi luis mariano
c'est une image de dire non je devrais
dire sa voix de tête se situe entre tino
rossi et luis mariano
c'est à dire que tatiana balavoine et
mariano vaut mieux mettre mariano devant
toujours est il que la voix de cheval de
daniel balavoine niveau la faveur d'une
jeunesse angoissé qui se cherchent ou
dans l'inquiétude et qui se retrouvent
ou dans les chiottes pour fumer du
haschich les fans donc sont folles de
balavoine
il y a deux ans lors d'un gala de
soutien organisée au profit des
organisateurs de gala de soutien
on a vu leur père du tueur sonar et
boudry pousser des cris et se griffer la
poitrine quand balavoine est entré en
scène
nous aimons tous cependant j'en profite
pour dire que nous aimons tous eve
ruggieri ici c'est pas parce qu'elle la
france inter nous l'aimons comme toute
la france l'aiment parce que c'est une
femme extrêmement intelligente et
sensible avec un coeur gros comme ça de
ce côté gros comme ça de l'autre
[Rires]
en fait une fausse mec t'as vu l'autre
jour au restaurant chinois
une sainte femme et puis brutalement
balavoine en a assez de la chanson
certes c'est bien payé mais ya pas de
cantine ni ticket restaurant c'est le
découragement
un autre que lui se serait mise à boire
c'est ce qu'il fait il n'y a pas de
raison que les autres puis sa vie se
délabre peu à peu pendant que sa femme
jouy en josas c'est lui qui garde les
gonesse encore livrés
c'est un rituel mort s'était vanté un
sens d'agde et la grossièreté n'est pas
préservée merci de m'aider histoire mais
je vous aide m et puis un jour sur le
planeur jaurès résumé les chapitres
précédents dans la gamme balavoine
chanteur de son métier se retrouve un
iguane banc et puis un jour sur le
plateau d'une chaîne de télévision dont
je tairai le nom pour ne pas faire de
publicité à antenne 2 daniel balavoine
fait la rencontre de sa vie françois
mitterrand lermytte lhermitte par
françois mitterrand le vieux militant
socialiste tendance ignace de loyola à
soi mitterrand la gauche de bénitier qui
rend compte balavoine et lui dit tu
seras un homme mon fils et balavoine
répond et mon cul c'est du poulet déçu
déçu daniel balavoine quitte alors
mitterand qui se drape dans sa dignité
et dans son cache col de chez monsieur
ségala il cache col de chemise de ces
gars là c'est de la pure laine vierge
pour faire encore plus évident sur les
affiches qui
pauvre balavoine le voici qui erre de
taverne au bistrot gorges et d'amertume
et de mauvaise bière à minuit il est
ivre mort et puis sur les voitures
garées une place de l'hôtel de ville
c'est à ce moment là qu'il fait la
seconde rencontre politique de sa
carrière en la personne de jacques
chirac qui sortait de son bureau au même
moment jeune homme dit le maire de paris
moi je fais où on dit de faire et
joignant le geste à la parole il lui a
pris le caniveau
quelques jours plus tard balavoine de
plus en plus écoeurés par la politique
reprenait le chemin de son sud ouest et
sur le quai de la gare d'austerlitz il
croisa georges marchais qui s'était
trompé de gare et qui partait pour
l'urss où elle espérait se faire refaire
la gueule par un derrière aux log de
match pour le moment je me demande si
vous n'exagérez pas du tout c'est votre
fille c'est quoi le communisme sans qui
balavoine de plus en plus en quête
d'idéal politique
le communisme il marchait c'est quand
les pauvres ils sont riches et qu'elle
est riche ils sont paumés que c'est les
chefs de bureau qui commande et on vire
giscard et en fout sa femme en taule au
pôle nord 1 et monopole des bonnes de
plus en plus sombre et déçu balavoine
monta dans le train tandis qu marché
poursuivait son chemin et dans sa femme
un coup de pompe dans le cul car elle
traînait la patte en portant les valises
dans le train balavoine rencontrera le
président qui partait en week-end on
était mardi soir vous vous représenter
aux 81 monsieur président de mandales
pauvres gens terre ça dépend du
président c'est quand à c'est en mai
l'élection en mai à mamers et dimanche
11 septembre
parce qu'elle dimanche la chasse a
remarqué en mai la chasse est fermée
alors peut-être bien je me présenterais
quand même
et après ça pauvre pomme ça vous étonne
qui en est dès qu'ils font campagne pour
coluche alors alors quand même d'autant
plus que là c'est un scoop sensationnel
que je vous donne là j'ai reçu des
cabinets de coluche du cabinet tout une
invitation à souper danse et qui venait
d'ailleurs monsieur coluche je me laisse
entendre que le portefeuille de la
justice pourrait éventuellement mechouar
après l'automne c'est l'hiver à
l'automne c'est à cause de pierrefitte
c'est l'automne parce que c'est un vieux
truc juste de feuilles qui dépasse on
trouve pas d'autre part monsieur coluche
ne cachant pas son désir de voir
balavoine au ministère de la culture
je me serais demander la tête d'un futur
coban partouze c'est pourquoi
exceptionnellement vraiment
exceptionnellement je demande
l'acquittement
oh
[Musique]
je devais intervenir de ce président
pourrait signaler à ce qu'ils n'ont pas
encore entendu que dans ma rencontre
avec jacques chirac
une main aussi dit autre chose une
phrase qu'il a répétée plus tard dans un
discours devant du monde ça veut dire
qu'il faut quand même le faire qu'il
fallait d'urgence mettre un frein à
l'immobilisme
je vous la livre en prie je vous la
livre l'éguille ya pas de problème à
l'essai ya encore dix ans la tête non
non
[Musique]